Etihad Airways have today unveiled new product and service offerings...
...with a completely reimagined approach to air travel.
The Residence,...
...the only three-room cabin in the sky,...
...features a living room, separate double bedroom and en suite shower room...
...plus a personal butler.
The A380 First Apartment.
It's a fully private suite with separate reclining lounge seat,...
...full-length bed, personal vanity unit, wardrobe and minibar.
The Boeing 787 First Suite has a 26-inch-wide Poltrona Frau seat...
...that converts to a comfortable 80.5-inch fully flat bed.
The Business Class Studio, available on both the A380 and Boeing 787,...
...has a luxurious standard that you usually find in first class...
...for the rest of the industry.
Economy class is also new.
It's an ergonomic seat,...
...a smart seat design with fixed-wing headrest.
The lobby aboard the A380 is a communal area where guests can gather,...
...mingle and enjoy Etihad's world-class service.